بتطوراتها للاذهان جبهات اخرى ساخنه شكلت
محطات مفصليه في عمر الحرب وبينها حصار
ماريوبل وتحديدا حصار كتيبه ازوف لاسابع
في مصنع ازوف ستال الصلب اخر معاقل القوات
الاوكرانيه واوده المعركه والحصار وفقا
للمسؤولين الاوكرانيين بارواح ما يزيد عن
25 الف مدني خرسون ايضا هي مركز المحافظه
الوحيد الذي استطاعت القوه الروسيه
السيطره عليه خلال حربها على اوكرانيا مع
انطلاق الدبابات والمدرعات الروسيه من شبه
جزيره القرن في يوم الحرب الاول لكنه
هجوما اوكرانيا مضضا هي اغسطس من العام
الماضي فرضا انسحابا روسيا من المدينه في
نوفمبر وتم تفجير الجسور بين ضيفتي نهر
دنيبرو وخاركاب في شرق اوكرانيا على بعد
نحو 20 ميلا فقط جنوب الحدود الروسيه
الاوكرانيه وهي ثاني اكبر مدينه في
اوكرانيا وشكلت هدفا رئيسيه للجيش الروسي
منذ بدايه الحرب استعادها الاوكرانيون عبر
هجوم بدا في الخامس من شهر سبتمبر الماضي
وتبقى معركه كييف واحده من اهم المعارك في
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حينما سعت القوات
الروسيه للسيطره على
اجل تطويق ومحاصره العاصمه الاوكرانيه من
الغرب والتراث القوات الروسيه حينها مع
تقدم الجيش الاوكراني للانسحاب في الثاني
من ابريل من العام الماضي بينما كشف في
بوتشا عن اكثر من مقبره جماعيه ضمت نحو
458 جثه